- Hello everyone.
Thanks a lot for coming in today.
I appreciate all of you being here.
My name is Nits Jeganathan,
and I'm the product
lead for AWS Transform,
and joining me today
is Srinivas Singaraju.
Please introduce yourself, Singaraju.
- Hello, everyone.
I'm Srinivas Singaraju with IDEMIA,
focusing on technology
transformation at IDEMIA.
- Yeah, and joining me also is Rahul Chugh
and he's an SA in AWS.
Please introduce-
- Yeah.
Hi everyone, I'm Rahul Chugh.
I'm AI Acceleration SA, so
I essentially help partners
to accelerate migrations
and modernization on AWS
using AI and GenAI technologies.
- Excellent. All right, thank you.
So today we are gonna be talking about
how our customers, IDEMIA,
have used AWS Transform
to break down the technical debt
that they have built over 25 years.
While we are walking through this journey,
we'll also like explain
the new capabilities
that we are introducing into AWS Transform
for .NET as well.
Okay?
Just before we get into this, I wanna like
kind of get a show of
hands from all of you.
How many of you know about
AWS Transform for .NET?
This is our agentic AI
service we launched.
Okay, that's a few of you, and some of you
are like fairly new, so
I'll kind of set the context
a little bit and then we can, you know,
dive into some of the new
capabilities that we have added.
So the first thing that I wanna talk about
is why does customer wanna modernize
their .NET applications, right?
Like from Windows to Linux.
And a lot of customers
who have applications
that are written in .NET Framework,
they are like 20 plus years old,
and a lot of these legacy applications
can run only on Windows, and
that is preventing customers
from taking advantage
of the new technologies
and flexibility that is available to them
by moving to Linux.
Like if you move to Linux, you can run it
on different instances, whether it is x86,
or even Graviton instances.
You can run them as
containers, take advantage
of the scalability in that sense,
or like you can run
them as Lambdas, right?
And just running it on Windows
kind of prevents you from doing that.
So that is one of the
reasons why customers
want to move out of, you
know, Windows ecosystem,
but there are other advantages too.
Some of the significant ones is definitely
the operating cost reduction
because the licensing costs
that they have to pay
for the Windows licenses
is no longer applicable,
so they're able to save
up to 40% on some applications, right?
And just by moving to the
latest versions of Windows,
that number like 1.5 to 2x,
that's coming from Microsoft
because of the complete
performance upgrades
across the entire stack, right?
The SDKs, the libraries,
all of those are improving,
so just by moving from .NET Framework
to .NET 8.0 or .NET
10.0, you are expecting
to see up to 2x performance improvement.
And finally, I think the
point that I talked about
is there's a scalability, right?
Once you can run it on
Linux and as a container,
you have a world of options.
You have a lot more options
of like how you wanna scale,
how you wanna build new capabilities.
All of those open up to you.
So that's one of the reasons.
What we have seen is up
to 70% of our customers
who are running Windows on AWS today,
they're increasingly adopting Linux
for their Windows
ecosystem of applications.
All right, so that sounds great, right?
But then what is preventing customers
from actually transforming
their applications?
But it is not exactly
straightforward as that, right?
So for example, in order to
port your legacy applications,
you wanna first analyze the code,
identify incompatibilities that are there
between the previous version
and the current versions,
and the longer the
version, like for example
Framework 3.5 and you
wanna move to .NET 8.0,
a lot of those libraries are stale.
You need to find different libraries,
different mechanisms of
doing some of those things.
And then you have to port the code,
and finally validate and deploy.
Even though it is showing this
as a single streamlined workflow,
it is never that straightforward.
Each one of these is
a loop and developers,
as you know, you go make a change
and then all of a sudden
there is 200 builders, right?
And then you have to go back and fix it,
then the libraries are wrong, so it just
is a very cumbersome and, you know,
undifferentiated heavy
lifting for our customers,
because they would rather
wanna spend this time
on focusing on the core competencies
of building new capabilities
rather than trying
and maintaining old
code, which they may not
fully understand, because
the folks who wrote this code
no longer there or they have moved on
to something else, right?
So it requires collaboration
across multiple organizations
and it just is very slow progress.
And this is exactly where AWS
Transform for .NET comes in.
For folks who are not familiar with it,
this is the first agentic AI experience
for transforming your .NET
Framework applications
to .NET 8.0, and now we are supporting
to .NET 10.0 at scale.
So essentially, like if you
have hundreds of applications,
thousands of applications,
we are supporting those
in an agentic workflow
model where we are shifting
the developer's role
from that of an executor
to a reviewer, right?
So it's a human in the
loop reviewing off the code
that is being transformed, and
how we are able to do that,
we have a .NET domain expert agent
that we have built on our own
using open source projects
and all of our learnings that
we have done over many years,
and we are using that as a mechanism
to form a unified web experience
where customers can
point to the repositories
and we'll do all the transformation,
you know, like developers can review it
before they deploy to their
production and ground.
So just by doing that, right,
customers can essentially
offload some of the tedious
tasks that I was talking about
and they can achieve
acceleration of up to 4x,
and this is some of these
numbers that we have seen
by working with customers.
We launched the service in preview
in re:Invent of last year
and we launched the service
in general availability in May 15 of 2025.
So in the last six months,
customers have been
playing around with it
and transforming at scale
and they've been porting
hundreds of applications
and they are boosting
application performance,
scalability, and things like that as well.
So what has changed?
Maybe I'll just touch
upon what has changed
from the GA to now.
It's been six months, right?
There are things that we have learned
from talking to customers,
understanding what capabilities
that they wanna go and
build this product further.
So one of the first
things that we have done
is expanding support to .NET 10.0.
And Microsoft has released
a new .NET version,
and you know customers,
now they don't want
just to go to 8.0, they wanna go to 10.0,
so we are supporting that.
And more importantly, they
wanna support .NET Standard,
because most of the customers
with a large legacy,
you know like a real estate portfolio,
they would wanna actually
do it incrementally.
So they don't wanna break compatibilities
with their .NET Framework
application section,
and if you don't wanna move everything
in one go to .NET 8.0 and you wanna keep
some of the applications in Standard,
that allows you to actually do
it in an incremental fashion.
So the strangler fig
pattern instance, right?
So that's why we added support
for .NET Standard as well.
And more importantly, if you think
of your .NET Framework applications
as a three-layered cake,
what we have done at GA was
transforming the middle layer,
the business logic, but customers
couldn't get their UI ported.
Like we know most of the
Framework applications
were written on web forms
and they didn't have
an exact straightforward
way to transform that.
So what we have done
now is we have enabled
the same agentic workflow for
transforming your web forms
to Blazor and this allows
customers to transform
a lot of these legacy
applications in one go, right?
And also the Entity Framework
and ADO, ORM support,
essentially what happens
is that if your code
was written for database
access in Framework
with Entity or ADO.NET, we are able
to port those corresponding
changes to the .NET 8.0 as well.
This is one of those things
where if we didn't do this,
customers have to go manually
go make these changes,
and with the agentic experience,
customers are able to
take advantage of that.
And that is only the
feature capabilities, right?
But there is also the developers.
Like we've been talking
with a lot of developers
and one of the things that they
have provided feedback to us
is that they wanna see that
once the transformation begins,
they wanna be able to
provide fine-grain inputs.
They wanna be able to customize it.
They wanna be able to nudge
it in a specific direction.
So to support that, what we have done
is we have provided an
editable transformation plan.
So what is the transformation plan?
Rahul will show a demo of how this works,
but essentially it's a high-level flow
of all the steps that
the agent is gonna take
to modernize your application portfolio
and customers will be able to say
like, "Okay, make this choice.
Go to this version instead
of the other version."
Those kind of changes, like you know,
that recommendation is
going to come there.
And then also, you know,
they wanna understand
how much time it's gonna take.
Rather than being a black
box, be more transparent.
Give me more feedback on
exactly how long you're taking,
which builder are you stuck on?
Those kind of details, we
are now providing those
to customers as well.
And also, finally, they
wanna be able to use
a coding assistant of their choice.
Let's say they're using Kiro.
They wanna be able to continue the work
that AWS Transform has
done, take it to Kiro,
finish those changes, and then try again,
so fix issues and do it
in an iterative format,
and we are enabling those
kind of functionalities today.
There will be a transformation plan
with the next steps as a markdown,
which you can directly feed
to Kiro, complete the job,
and then run the transformation again.
And finally, one of the things that we had
was it's available in two experiences.
Whether you start in
web or whether you use
Visual Studio IDE, you can
see the work that is happening
across both of these together.
So now there is no longer the separation
of if I'm doing the work in IDE,
I cannot see what's happening
on the web experience
and vice versa.
So it is now one unified workspace
for your teams to collaborate together.
So those are the functionalities
that we have added,
but enough about what the potentials are.
I wanna have one of our customers
who have used this service
show you how they have used AWS Transform
to solve their problems,
and that would act
like a guidance for some of the challenges
that you yourself may
face and how AWS Transform
can help you there.
I'll invite Srinivas to kind
of share those details here.
Srinivas?
(crowd clapping)
- Thank you, Nits.
So we at IDEMIA, we service 45
plus DMVs across the country.
Any one of you who has a driver's license
in the United States, the chances are
that we would've touched your life
in some or the other form.
This particular solution that we took
through the transformation process
is one of the critical products
that we offer as a service,
and that's for certifying.
As you enter the DMV, you
go through a knowledge test,
and then a skills test,
and then kind of, you know,
you go through the whole process
of getting your driver's license.
As part of that, this product
was built sometime back
and the legacy state was like a typical
monolithic application
that we have been deploying
for a while with a thick
client WPF-based application
and then .NET Framework 3.5
with a SQL Server database
as the backend.
Nothing fancy, but kind of, you know,
a critical application.
As we started embarking on the journey
of trying to scale it up
across multiple customers
and multiple types of users
that we had to cater to,
we started realizing
that there are gonna be
some significant challenges.
These are some of the challenges,
not just all-encompassing,
that we encountered
that we needed some answers for.
As we started ramping up, we realized
that the technical debt was piling up
with outdated infrastructure architecture
based on .NET Framework
that was no longer scalable
and limiting us from
being able to containerize
and kind of move to the next level.
Additionally, we started encountering
higher cost of ownership
from a performance
and the legacy applications
that were running
on a Windows environment
and could not be ported
into a Linux setting.
And we also started seeing
some security challenges
that we needed to address.
Particularly with the
space that we operate in,
compliance is a big thing that we need
to be very careful about
because we deal with PII
on a continuous basis,
and also making sure
that not only we're compliant
with the regulatory standards,
but we also need to be ahead of all those
nation-state actors that
we need to worry about.
So kind of we needed to think
about what we need to do.
And it also started kind of
as we started scaling up,
we started noticing some
customer satisfaction issues
were starting to creep up.
So customers started
complaining that, "Hey,
the performance is not at the level
that we are looking for
or we were hoping for.
What can you guys do about that?"
When we started thinking about, okay,
we need to start transforming
what we are doing right now.
So we realized that kind of, you know,
from a technical debt perspective,
what are we looking at?
The manual deployment
process was taking longer
than what we were hoping for.
The incompatibility with the
lightweight Linux containers
that we needed to address,
and also the auto scaling.
We were setting up the environments
for like kind of, you know,
the worst-case scenario
but not using it on a regular basis,
which meant that the cost of ownership
was obviously kind of
going through the roof.
And the restricted
integration for CICD pipelines
that we wanted to bring bear.
The cloud-native
capabilities that the team
was hoping to leverage, we were
not able to get any of that
in place because of the
legacy architecture.
Additionally, we also started noticing
that kind of, you know,
there were some 32-bit
versus 64-bit inefficiencies
that we needed to address
and memory management
and garbage collection.
Those of you who are familiar
with .NET applications
and who have used the
older .NET Frameworks,
you would've definitely experienced
these kind of pain points
on a continuous basis.
And if you ask me what
kept me up at night,
there were occasions where
I had to jump on calls
to figure out what was going on,
and our team was not too happy about that.
The end of life of Windows 2012 server
also kind of accelerated the process
that we needed to
transform our application.
And also, as I mentioned,
the overprovisioning
of EC2 instances and then
the amount of storage
that we had to overprovision.
I have my colleague also here
who kind of lived that nightmare with me.
We kind of started thinking
what can we do, okay?
And 99% of the time we started realizing
that majority of the resources
were actually sitting idle
and we needed to address that debt.
The higher capacity
needed during usage peaks,
which were not uniform
but kind of, you know,
we saw the ebbs and flows of that
that we needed to deal with.
As we started looking at
these problems, we realized
that we needed to tackle them
sooner rather than later.
As I also mentioned,
couple of other things
in terms of the security
challenges that we encountered.
The TLS 1.0 versus TLS 1.3 support
that was limited in terms
of what we were having
in .NET 3.5 and obsolete
code access security
versus the modern .NET
8.0 Framework security.
That was something that
we were looking for.
The weak authentication schemes
that we had to deal with.
Minimal protection for CSRF and, you know,
stack trace being very poor
in .NET 3.5 versus .NET 8.0,
and insecure token storage practices
that we had to kind of deal with
as part of the 3.5 architecture
that we had in place.
So with that kind of, you
know, we set some goals
for modernizing our application
and the service that we were
offering to our customers.
We started talking to some
partners, Cloudhedge and Amazon.
We realized that we need to containerize
as quickly as possible, moving it
to a lightweight Linux container model.
We needed to improve our security posture,
bring down the total cost of ownership,
and more importantly, be
able to go cross-platform,
which was limited the .NET
3.5 that we were experiencing.
How did we achieve that?
We started talking, as I said,
to Cloudhedge and to Amazon
and realized this is the
ideal application state
that we needed to get to.
As we can see, we started
getting a little bit
more cloud-native, which
was not the case previously.
We needed to host it in a
multi-availability zone model,
which was not the case previously,
particularly containerizing
that and kind of using
the ECRs for managing those containers
and then the EKS to store our containers.
And we also, as a part of the journey,
we started, before the
availability of the SQL Server
Transform platform, we
started kind of migrating
some of that into Postgre's Aurora SQL.
So as we started doing that, we realized
that kind of, you know,
there's gotta be a better way,
and that's when we talked to
Amazon about the AWS Transform
being the right platform for us
to take us to the next level.
Think of it that each and every area
that we're talking about
has like kind of a codebase
that's, you know, unique to
each DMV that we need to deploy,
and when we kind of
factor in across 45 DMVs,
that's not a simple task,
either for the development team
or for the SRE team on our side.
So that's when, with this architecture,
what we started noticing was that close
to four times efficiency, as
Nits had already pointed out
in his presentation.
What we realized is like, you know,
that the team started seeing
that kind of efficiency
as we started transforming
to the target state.
The results that we
achieved as part of that
were like kind of, you know,
the most important thing
for me was to improve the resiliency
and the uptime availability.
With using EKS containers across multiple
availability zones, it
has helped us actually
to kind of have a better uptime
and improve on the
performance bottlenecks.
As a matter of fact, as
we started doing that,
we realized that we were running into
a little bit of issues on
moving it into GovCloud.
We successfully kind of overcame that
and deployed it into GovCloud,
which was a huge step forward for us.
The four times faster piece,
the application transformation,
previously the team gave me an estimate
of almost like, per DMV we were looking
at close to six months.
So overall to transform
the entire application,
we were looking at orders of magnitude
of like two to three years.
I'm sure every one of you here knows
that we don't have that kind of luxury,
'cause technology keeps changing
and we need to cater to
the needs of our customers
on a continuous basis.
So with AWS Transform,
it actually helped us
complete the transformation
of the application layer
in less than like kind of
quarter of that timeframe.
So that's a huge thing for
us, because kind of, you know,
the longer we sit in the older platform,
it not only is increasing my costs,
it's also like kind of
keeping up the security holds
on a continuous basis
that we need to deal with.
The reduced total cost of ownership.
We started realizing that we're gonna get
about like at least 30% in
terms of cost reduction.
If we had to provision those
extra resources previously,
now with the auto-scaling properties
that I can kind of set efficiently,
we're able to actually
recognize that 30% savings
in terms of the dollars
that we're spending.
The modern deployment
practices like being able
to kind of go to the
CICD pipeline efficiently
that was lacking previously,
now we're able to reduce that
by 35% by reaching the time...
The time taken is reduced by 35%.
And more importantly, security.
I'm sure all of you kind
of have gone through
some sort of a security nightmare
as you're kind of building
your applications.
With .NET 8.0, we can leverage
the newer security features
that .NET 8.0 offers, particularly
migrating our application
from a 32-bit to 64-bit and be able
to kind of take care of all those CVEs
that we had to deal with
previously proactively
using the .NET 8.0
Framework kind of, you know,
is a huge win for us.
So this is a reaction from our director
of software engineering.
He had to deal with this
nightmare application for years,
and this is verbatim what he said.
As we kind of leveraged AWS Transform,
it helped us speed up
the full transformation
by four times and more
efficiently host the software
on a Linux versus a Windows server.
What does it mean for us
from a business standpoint
is that now I can actually
take this application
and kind of go to a true
software-as-a-service model,
which we could not do previously.
That's kind of in a nutshell
what we have been through
as an AWS Transform partner
and Cloudhedge partner,
and Rahul is gonna take us through
how he helped us
transform our application.
- Thank you.
(crowd clapping)
Plenty of time, yeah.
All right, let's see how
that magic actually happens,
how the AWS Transform works.
It actually is pretty simple.
So it goes through three steps.
So first is analysis
followed by transformation
and then validation.
So as part of analysis, a
.NET agent is essentially
a deep domain expert and its intelligence
is built on top of Amazon bedrock models
that we have trained.
It enables code integration from GitHub,
Bitbucket, GitLab, and a
few more other sources,
wherever your code resides today.
The way analysis works is
it starts with at first
identifying the .NET
version of the project
that you have out there.
It determines what are
different project types
that are there and then
it looks at the code
and the dependencies
between different projects
and between different repositories
that you have provided it to analyze.
So once the analysis completes,
it gives you a pre-transformation
analysis report,
and using that report, you can look at
what are the different things
that will be transformed
during the whole process?
And you can look at the complexity as well
for different projects that
are out there in your solution.
So based on the codebase dependencies
and the business
objectives that you state,
it delivers you a tailored
transformation plan.
So basically that's where you jump
into the transformation phase.
So this transformation
plan you can actually edit.
So it gives you some default plan.
You can add on top of
it what you want to do,
literally in plain English language.
It's LLM behind the
scenes, which understands
what needs to be done and it
transforms the code for you.
The transformation can handle
different project types.
It can handle your WCF
projects, Web API projects,
console applications, test projects,
and it basically offers you to put
some repository level configuration,
and you can provide third party
packages dependency as well
for the whole transformation to work
and complete eventually.
So in this transformation process,
it first transforms the code.
It tries to build it.
If it doesn't build, it tries to fix it,
and that keeps on happening
over and over again
in a loop behind the scenes
till you have a project
where, you know, it cannot no more do
any other thing out there
using AI at that moment.
So once that transformation completes,
it generates a transformation
report for you.
So in that transformation
report, it shows you
what all things have been transformed,
why things have been transformed,
and it gives you another
report, which is NextSteps.md,
basically a markdown file which tells you
what's actually not
transformed and it gives you
certain steps on how you can, you know,
further transform it.
Or another thing that you can do
is you can again run
the whole transformation
based on the knowledge
that you have right now.
Let's say, you know, some
dependency injection failed
that you have implemented.
Next time when you are
again running the Transform,
in your transformation steps, you can add
a custom step out there to
run a dependency injection
in a certain way so that
this time, you know,
that part of the project
is also transformed,
and you can keep doing
that over and over again
however many times you want to.
So once the transformation completes,
it basically generates a new
branch where all the code is
and you can merge it into
your production branch.
So as part of that transformation,
you know, when it ends,
it generates all that reports.
The next step as of this
journey is validation.
So AWS Transform, it automatically runs
your unit tests as well and it tells you
based on those unit tests as well
how much it succeeded, what's failed,
and it tries to fix that as well
as part of your whole
transformation plan itself,
or whatever it can.
It also generates Linux
readiness report for you
which you can review and
see if there are further
changes needed in the code at that time.
So that is another thing
that you can validate.
It generates a natural
language transformation summary
for you, which is again, you
know, a very detailed summary
of all the changes that are there,
all the build issues
that it has identified
for you to review, and
then again, you know,
you can further optimize.
So once the transformation completes,
it also generates an email for you.
So what basically that means is let's say
you start a transformation
and it tells you, you know,
it's gonna take three hours, let's say.
You don't have to sit
in front of your system.
You can leave it.
Once you get the email,
you can work on it.
So it basically is headless,
so behind-the-scene
transformation happens.
You don't have to, you
know, keep your screen open
or keep the project open.
It happens for you and you
can load that transformation
once you get that email.
Let's quickly look at a
demo out there for the same.
So we have two experiences here.
So first experience is
actually in the console,
and in the web console, when
you start AWS Transform,
you can create a job
there for transformation.
And the way to create a job,
obviously you can click on
Create job, but then at the same time
you can chat with AWS Transform
to create some of these jobs for you.
So here you can either chat with it
or you can click on the guided experience.
So let's select Windows
Modernization, because .NET
is part of that, and then you
select .NET transformation.
So once you select what kind of job it is,
you need to supply it the code.
How do you do that?
So either you can upload
it through an S3 bucket
or you can use AWS CodeConnections.
So the way AWS CodeConnection works
is there's a separate,
on AWS console itself,
you can go and configure your
GitHub or GitLab or Bitbucket.
You can supply the credentials there.
It is going to integrate there.
And here in the web console,
you provide details about that connector.
So once that connector is configured,
AWS Transform is able to pull
all different repositories
that are out there in
your GitHub or GitLab,
whichever source-code
repository you're using.
So all these repositories are pulled,
and then you can select
the specific repositories
that you want to modernize.
The way to do it is, let's say, you know,
I want to modernize this
one, Bob's Used Bookstore,
and then I know there's
a dependent repository
API test there.
So I would select both those repositories
so that when transformation
happens, it is able
to find those correlations
between repositories
and is able to transform
the whole codebase better.
So once you have supplied
these repositories,
there is another kind of dependency,
which is NuGet packages.
So these NuGet packages, you can either
supply those private NuGet packages
through Azure Artifact
store or you can actually
upload these packages through
the web console itself.
So this is, you know, one of
the most requested feature
that we had when we
had our product in beta
where a lot of customers,
they had these private
NuGet packages and they
wanted to, you know,
ensure when they're transforming,
those dependencies are resolved,
and now we are able to do that.
So once we have done that, you can review
all the dependent repositories
are configured correctly,
you can ensure all the dependent packages
are configured correctly, and then you can
approve and start that transformation.
So when the transformation
starts, it generates
a lot of logs for you, and
you can see all of that.
It is pretty verbose and shows you
all the things that it is doing.
You can, again, you know, you
have an option to sit there
or you can close it and come back
and start working on the
transformation again.
So here, you know, when I was
doing this transformation,
here you can see one of
the projects succeeded
and one of the projects failed.
So the repositories which succeeded,
it shows what all is succeeded,
and then whatever is
failed, you can actually
talk to the console
itself in natural language
and it can tell you what
all things you can do.
It also generates a next-steps
markdown file for you,
which will have all
that information for you
which you can, you know, again use
and again run the transformation
or fix a few things and
run the transformation.
Or you can use, if,
you know, AWS Transform
is not able to transform
after a certain point,
you can use other code
companions like Kiro
to continue the work of
transformation and complete it.
So this was our web console experience.
We have another experience, which is in
the Visual Studio IDE.
So as a .NET developer,
this is the default IDE
that all .NET developers use.
And you can install AWS
Toolkit with Visual Studio 2022
or Visual Studio 2026
and you'll get option
to transform there.
So here, you know, I'm starting
with a project out there,
which is on .NET Framework 4.8,
and I've installed AWS Toolkit out there.
So before I can start the transformation,
I need to configure AWS Toolkit
for AWS Transform to work.
So for that I can again go in
and the way, you know, I had set it up
with web earlier using
IAM Identity Center,
same thing you need to do here.
You basically give it
Identity Center credentials,
it is all set up, and then you
can start the transformation.
To start the transformation,
you can either put a solution
or you can put a project.
So you can right click on
your solution, let's say,
and then you just say, you
know, start the transform.
So when you do that, it basically
gives you two options here.
So you can see the workspace here,
and the second option that you see here
is what's the version you want to get to?
So currently we support .NET 8.0.
We also support .NET 10.0.
We support .NET Standard as
well as the target framework.
So how does workspace help?
So these workspaces that are out there,
let's say you have a team
of developers out there
and they all eventually want to work
on certain thing in the transform process.
So every transformation job that runs,
it runs in a workspace and that workspace
can be shared with multiple people
and multiple people can then
work on that transformation.
So again, you know, when
the transformation starts,
it starts with analysis
and it analyzes everything,
and at the end of analysis, it generates
an assessment report.
So you can, again, it's
the same kind of report
that you saw earlier with the web.
So you can look at this
report on complexity
of this transformation.
You know, a lot of times
it helps with estimation,
like when you're estimating how much time
it's gonna take to eventually, you know,
do the rest of the work that will be left.
So it's always helpful to look at all this
initial assessment
report that is out there.
And once your transformation completes,
it auto-generates a report for you,
which is the whole transformation report
on what has changed in
your transformation,
why it has changed in your transformation.
And it also generates a
next-steps file for you,
which contains all the things
about if something has failed,
what are the steps that
you can take to fix them?
Or it it might have,
you know, certain things
where it might not be
able to suggest to you
what you need to change,
but then you still need
to take some action.
So you can analyze them, and then again,
change your transformation plan,
run that transformation again,
and you can keep on
doing that incrementally.
So once you have completed
the whole transformation,
at that time, all the
files that are out there,
you can start merging.
You can either, you know,
look at them one by one,
compare them and then pull
them onto your system.
You can say click on save
changes for a particular file
and it will basically merge out there.
Or you can select everything, select all,
and do a single much easier option,
but then you can still
review each and every file
that is out there and what is changing.
And at the end of the transformation,
you can see newer framework.
That's our goal.
With that,
let's move to and see the full
stack Windows transformation,
the new features that we
have released, how they work.
I'll invite PM for the product.
- Okay, thank you, Rahul,
and as well as Srinivas
for that walkthrough.
(crowd clapping)
So what we have seen is now
for the .NET side, right?
Like so the .NET transformation, you know,
for how we are moving
customers from .NET framework
to .NET 8.0 or .NET 10.0.
Now, if you look at it
from a customer-objective
point of view, right?
Like if you wanna migrate
your legacy applications,
think of it as a three-layered cake.
We are now supporting web forms to Blazor
from the UI framework point of view.
We are supporting from the middle tier
for .NET Framework to .NET 8.0,
but that alone doesn't help
them complete the whole story.
So what we have launched today in GA
is a full-stack modernization agent.
So now we are able to
handle .NET Framework
to cross platform, web forms to Blazor,
but more importantly
now we are supporting,
if you have SQL Server, we are using
the same agentic experience
to actually transform them
into Aurora PostgreSQL Server as well.
So the main advantage of
this is that like customers
who have all of these legacy applications,
they can use the same mechanisms
they are used to for .NET
to start modernizing
their SQL servers as well.
And after that, once you have transformed
your entire application
stack, we are supporting
deploying those into a sandbox environment
so you can validate
the whole thing, right?
And this is one of the
big pieces of feedback
that we have gotten from customers
is I wanna be able to, you know,
like take this application,
test it that it's working
fine, and now that we have
full-stack capability of transformation,
you can actually put it in an environment
and test the functionality.
This is gonna help accelerate customers
modernizing into the newer .NET 8.0,
.NET 10.0 kind of level.
And one final piece is
that this whole service
is completely free for you to use, right?
Like this whole experience
in AWS Transform
for the Windows ecosystem
is free to use today.
And so yeah, we are
definitely looking forward
to seeing more use cases
that's coming, you know,
you can build and how we can
assist you on this process.
So the same sequence that
we had for .NET, right?
Like we have exactly a
similar flow here as well.
We are gonna do an analysis
and then we are gonna be like
identifying the database
schemas, the tables,
the views, and the indexes that you have,
and then we are gonna start the migrating,
like those schemas and all
the database-related items,
but more importantly
we are gonna also make
corresponding changes in the
application code as well.
So that means now you do
not actually have to go
make changes to the application.
So we identify the dependencies
between your .NET applications
and your SQL Server
and we as we migrate to Postgre's target,
we will make the corresponding changes
in your application code.
So you get a fully transformed
stack as part of this,
and then we'll help
you validate and deploy
in a new environment.
So this is the functionality
we launched today
and I wanna make sure that like all of you
are able to at least get
a sneak peek at this.
There is a session that we
are hosting tomorrow at 1:30,
and we have that information
on this in the next slide,
and we would love to have you there
and, you know, understand
a little bit more
and see what you can build
and take it from here, okay?
Yeah, and the interactive
demo which Rahul showed,
you can actually get it from that QR code,
and more you can see from our website.
And the session that we
are talking about tomorrow,
the full-stack SQL modernization,
there is a builder session
that you can actually get it,
and also there is, you know,
like a breakout session
where we will be talking
about this as well.
All right?
With that, yeah, I'm just,
you know, like cannot wait
for you to test it and give your feedback
and where you would love
to take this product next.
Thank you.
- Thank you.
- Thank you everyone
for your time-
- Thank you, everyone.
- [Nits] -and your
patience, appreciate it.
Thank you.